I emancipated myself so I was
emancipated at 15. why my parents are
going through their very very messy
divorce I kind of felt like I started
being used as a pawn in it so I got a
lawyer 15.
he was the father of a family friend of
ours and who's a family lawyer and so it
was a relatively not a difficult process
what did your parents say about you
getting emancipated if they try to stop
you from doing that my mom was on board
because she did not want me to be
involved in the divorce sure um you know
I won't get into details but it was my
dad who was I'm not very close with him
at the time he was the one that was
pulling me into it and so I went to him
and I said this is unacceptable I'm
doing this because of the things that
you are doing and the impact you're
having on our family so if it's not
contentious your parents can both sign
and if the judge agrees that it's okay
sure that is okay